a secretive annual meeting attended by
the world's Elite has AI top of the
agenda CNBC story open AIC CEO Sam
Altman joins Tech leaders and political
heavyweights at the selective annual
Bilderberg meeting in Lisbon Portugal
they're they're public about it now it's
no longer Builders yeah the meetings
agenda places a strong emphasis on
artificial intelligence and includes a
discussion on topics such as the banking
system China energy transition Europe
fiscal challenges in the industrial
policy and trade nato-russia
transitional threats Ukraine and U.S
leadership the three-day event attended
by approximately 130 participants from
23 different countries maintains which
prevent the disclosure of speakers
uh uh identities and affiliations the
clandestine nature of the meeting has
given rise to conspiracy theories uh but
organizers state that it facilitates
open and unrestricted discussions the
Bilderberg meeting established in 1954
aims to promote dialogue between Europe
and North America and these participate
as individuals rather than an official
capacity when a meeting like this
happened what do you think about this is
there anything behind it is it uh the
conspiracy theories do they have
anything right about this or is it just
guys coming together together to talk
about the future threats look I I love
conspiracy theories I'm actually
launching a new TV show that's expressly
about them but I like them as
entertainment there's a reason they're
called theories and not conspiracy facts
they've been is this news that rich
people who are powerful hang out with
each other and think they can run the
world no I mean go back to Bretton Woods
go back in time to any Elite that has
power that has money they think that
they can shape the future the
Rothschilds Bohemian Grove San Francisco
on and on and on and on medicis this
this yeah this isn't new back to
Machiavelli the prince you you name it
when it comes to AI you know I'm not a
I'm not a wonk okay uh I'm not a geek I
just don't buy this you know Skynet is
across the Horizon we're about to be the
the idea that we can't just pull the
plug at some point on this stuff when it
gets too scary trying to get a reference
very good yeah yeah I mean you know the
idea that it helps you write your
college essays okay that's really
exciting I mean okay but the idea that
this is some threat to humanity I'm open
to uh here people who are building this
stuff tell me yes this is the greatest
threat to humanity but while we've got
six million people crossing the border
illegally 110
000 people dying from fentanyl China
re-militarizing Russia with nuclear
weapons invading other people's
countries you know I'm not going to get
too excited about this stuff Tom
well I I think this has been going on
for a long time and you know you go back
to Rothschilds in the banking and you
know I I think that
when groups of people like this get
together it draws a lot of fire and a
lot of there's a lot of magnetism with
what's going on there uh and and I think
what's what's also going on is you've
got the purveyors of AI trying to get
the political Elite to calm down about
AI you have to remember what's going on
here there's a lot of money to be made
in these in these companies and a lot of
investment it's billions of dollars have
already been invested in AI so you have
Sam Altman open AI CEO and and um
y combinator frame incubator you know
saying Easy Does It Easy Does It yeah
there could be some things here but easy
does it meanwhile what they don't want
you this is a classic thing where I
think the purveyors of AI the inventors
and those operating companies and
Investments really don't want the
governments to come in and regulate it I
think this is this is let me ask a
question in different ways so either one
of you guys if you got an invitation to
go to the Builder to build a Bilderberg
meeting would you go to it if it's not a
bit I hate these people why would I go
okay so you have no desire to go to zero
but they want to get your perspective
your point of view okay I don't care
these people the kind of a diplomat are
you I'm not a diplomat you know what the
only other job was three jobs I do the
next Administration what's that uh do
National Security advisor I'd run
Personnel you know the only third one
for shits and green what's that I'd be
ambassador to the UN so I could walk in
there and the whole building would catch
a flame that's it diplomacy no forget
about it this is America it's about
leadership it's about being the greatest
nation on God's green earth these people
hate the people so the people that
attending people they hate the people
they do of course they hate the people
they chose the wrong person in in 2016.
they chose the wrong box won the brexit
vote they chose the wrong person in
Hungary they hate the choice of the
people why is populism a dirty word
think about that for a second populism
is a dirty word
excuse me it the thing you're doing is
popular with the most people
that tells you everything you need to
know when the left made populism a
pejorative you realize what they think
of the average person I traveled with
President Trump on Air Force One to
Youngstown Ohio now Youngstown is deep
Rust Belt okay we got off Air Force One
at a military base no press no nothing
he got into the Beast we had about a 20
minute ride to the stadium okay on the
left hand side all we saw was shuttered
closed steel mill you know broken glass
broken windows on on the other side of
the road people modestly dressed with
their children on the side of the road
waving a little stars and stripes we get
to the stadium the boss is in the back
with the VIPs I decide to go into the
pit take selfies with people I'd
realized
that these are all Democrats their dads
were Democrats their grandparents worked
in the mill when he came out on stage
with Melania he couldn't give a speech
for minutes because they were screaming
USA USA USA those are the people the
bilderbergers hate
the people who built America by the
sweat of their brow I have no interest
hanging out with those people got it I
was gonna say they they were telling us
there's an invitation for you but go you
go
I was trying to get you I'll do the
helicopter right they have no interest
for you I'll do that now you're saying
that no so you just heard his answer the
answer is no and I'll counter that
Sebastian I agree with you and about
[Music]
94.625 of what you just said I agree
with Trader very specific numbers yep
but I would go you I would go and if
they're going to invite the Trojan Horse
to their con Fab I'm going would you
touch the Trojan Horse never so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]